[تصفيق]
ولم يخل
في خلدي ان شيئا من هذا القبيل سوف يحدث
في امريكا الجريمه الوحيده التي هي
التي يجب ان اقوم بها هي ان ادافع عن
بلادي من محاولات تدميرها منذ بالبدايه
الديمقراطي كانوا يتجسسون على حمله هل
تذكرون ذلك فقد هاجموني من خلال جمله من
عمليات التحقيقات غير الحقيقيه روسيا
روسيا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا وعمل وكذلك كذبه
العزل الاولى وكذبت العزل الثانيه
وعمليه
الغاز غير الدستوريه على مقر سكني في
مرلاجو
وما قامت به الاف بي اي التي
تقوم
بالانصياح للجمهوريين
وعدم حصولهم على تاييد من المشرعين
الملايين من
المصوطين والناخبين الذين قاموا بتاييد
وحتى
ما تم قلبي الاشياء راسا على عقب محاوله
عدم الكشف النقاب عن حقيقه اسره بايدن
التي اظهرت ان ثمه فارقا كبيرا تزيد عن
سبعه خمس
وكنا نحن بحاجه الى اقل من ذلك كنا بحاجه
الى سته عشر الف صوت فقط كان ذلك ليصب في
مصلحه لان بلادنا تسير نحو الجحيم
عملاء الاستخبارات ال51 الذين قالوا هنتر
بايدن الذي قام بنشر حمل حمله معلومات
مضلله حول روسيا هل تتذكرون ذلك
وقد تم تاكيد هذا الامر بشده من قبل الاف
بي اي عندما كانوا يعلمون ان الامر لم يكن
حمله تظليلًا من الجانب الروسي هو ان
انتخابات من هذا القبيل لا تحدث في عالم
ثالث والان يتدحت يتحدثون عن تدخل في
انتخابات على نطاق لم نشهدها في بلادنا
التي وهذه التحقيقات التي تراسها
الذي ناصر تلك الحمله على انه
الذي
قال بانه سوف ينال من الرئيس ترامب باي
ثمن كان دون ان يعلم اي شيء عني
وقد تبين من خلال كل نظر كافه الاطراف بما
في ذلك الديمقراطين وكلهم خلصوا بانه ما
من جريمه وقعت
وما من جريمه ابدا
[تصفيق]
حتى اناس
من قبل
المعيدين قالوا بانه ما من جريمه اقترفت
هذه اهانه على جبين بلادنا لا يمكن قبولها
هذا يذكرنا ما الذي حدث في افغانستان حيث
تركنا اكثر من
85 مليار دولار ثمن معدات عسكريه الافضل
في العالم وفقدنا اكثر من 13
جنديا عسكريا فضلا عن اشخاص فقدوا اطرافهم
هناك
الاوقات التي تعد الاكثر حرجه حرجا
لبلادنا في التاريخ وبعد ذلك
الحديث عن جرى الحديث عن الهيمنه في مجال
الطاقه
في خلال سته اشهر واسرع من كل اسرع من اي
دوله اخرى
ولو نظرتم
الى المدن التي يحكمها ديمقراطيون فهناك
الجرائم التي تحدث
والتهديدات التي
تتعلق
بالسلاح النوويه وهي مساله لم تتطرق اليها
اداره بايدن
والحديث والحديث عن ما قد تفضي اليه
الامور الى حرب عالميه نوويه ثالثه ونحن
ليس بعيدين عن هذا الامر فضلا عن الاقتصاد
الذي شلت اطرافه بحكم تضخم والقوات
العسكريه التي كانت قد الحقت هزيمه بداعش
قالوا باننا لم نفعل ذلك لكن سارق الامر
فقط اربعه اسابيع قيل اربعه اشهر استطعنا
التخلص من البغدادي
والان قد عززوا من جهود من خلال
تقديمي لائحه اتهامات الى الرئيس الخامس
والاربعين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
75 مليون صوتا هذا ما حصلت عليه وهو يفوق
ما ناله اي رئيس حكم هذه البلاد
الاجنحه هناك بعض الديمقراطين المتطرفين
في اتلانتا مثلا الذي يفعل كل ما بوسعه من
اجل اتهام حتى من خلال الحديث عن مكالمات
اجريتها مع رئيس اوكرانيا قيل من نظرهم
بانها هي المكالمه المثاليه ما من شخص قال
لي بانه
لا يجب علي ان اناقش هذه المساله عبر
الهاتف لكن ما من شيء قيل من قبيل الغلط
وكنا استمرينا
وقد استمر الحديث عن عن عمليات التزوير في
الانتخابات والاسم في جورجيا وهناك اناس
كثر بما في ذلك
بعض المحامين الذين لم يعثروا على اي
اخطاء او اي عيوب تتعلق باجراء اتصال من
هذا القبيل
هذه القضيه المزيفه فقدت
قد قدمت من اجل التدخل بانتخابات عام 2024
ويجب اسقاطها على الفور
الذي الذين يقومون بازعاجي ومضايقه
كل اتباعه
حتى من خلال
الانتخابات وصناديق الاقتراع
حتى بطريقه الانتخابات التي تم تصميمها من
قبل الكونجرس وبموجب القانون يفترض
ليفترض بي ان اقوم بالتناقش مع مساله
اداره الارشيفات الوطنيه
لكن هناك منظمه
متطرفه تتحدث عن حقوق الانسان لكنها خطره
بطريقه ليصعب تخيلها هذا ما يجب علينا ان
نتعامل معه لكن ما من جرميه
بموجب قانون السجلات الامر لا يتعلق بهذه
المساله كنا نفاوض
بنوايا حسنه وبطريقه جيده من اجل اعاده
بعض وكافه المستندات التي كانت موجوده على
الملا وفي وضح النهار والتي كانت موجوده
في واعادتها الى البيت الابيض كما فعل اي
رئيس سابق لكن عن لكن عندما قام بعض
المسؤولين من الاف بي اي
ووزاره العدل طلبته من محامي ان يعرض
عليهم غرفه التخزين التي كانت المستندات
مغلقه وموجوده بداخلها
وكان هناك طلب قيل لي بانه هل يمكنكم ان
تضعوا قفلا اضافيا وامتثلنا للامر
الامر مختلف عن اداره
وكذلك
الحمله اللاحقه كانت من قبل بعض وكلاء
الذين اخذوا كل شيء بما في ذلك الجواز
السفري وسجلات الطبيه الجميع اصيب بصدمه
ولم نسمع عن
عن غاره على منزل بهذا القبيل واعلم ان
التعديل الرابع يقوم بحمايه عمليات الضغط
والتفتيش لكنهم فعلوا هذا الامر لان
نظامنا العدلي قد بات خاليا من القانون
ويستخدمونه الان فضلا عن اي اشياء اخرى من
اجل الفوز في الانتخابات من الواضح بانهم
لا ينظرون الي من خلال
من خلال قانون السجلات بل جاؤوا بامر جديد
وينظرون اليه من خلال قانون التجسس
الذي يعود للعام
1917 ويحمل في طياته عقوبه الموت حتى ان
الامر لا يرتبط بالحصول بصوره علنيه على
هذه الصناديق ووضعها في منزل هو الذي
الامر الذي فعله الرئيس اوباما ورونالد
ريجن وبوش الكل قد فعل هذا الامر نفسه
وحتى هيلر
احتفظت بخمسه وثلاثين الف بريد الكتروني
كان لدار في ذلك وما من احد يفعل الامر
وردز الفعل مثل جون بايدن
المدعي المجنون
بالاضافه الى اخرين ممن يقولون بان الامور
اكثر سوءا مما تبدوا
ان جو بايدن قد
استحوذ على اعداد كبيره من المستندات بما
في ذلك تلك التي تتعلق تاون وتصل قيمتها
بصفقات تصل الى عشره مليون دولار
والمكتب غير المحمي في بنسلفانيا الذي بات
معروفا للعامه
حتى بما في ذلك
المساندات السريه التي تركت هناك ولعل
الامر الاكثر اهميه بانه لديه اكثر
انه لديه
اكثر من
مبلغ يفوخه
18 الف دولار التي يرفض التخلي عنها
والعمليه
قد تكون تلقائيا لو حصلت على تلك
المستندات السريه بايدن كان نائبا للرئيس
وما من حق له ان يقوم بالحصول على تلك
المستندات لانه
لانه
يجب ان يصنف بموجب قانون القانون الجنائي
لكنهم لا يتبعون القانون تلك
الفعل تحمل عقوبه كبيره
ولا يمكن تقديم اي اعذار لهذا التصرف من
قبل الديمقراطيين
لكنه لم يلاحق ولم تتم مضايقته
على غرار ما يتعرض له الناس الذين يعملون
معي
وكان هناك الالاف من المستندات التي حصل
عليها والامر كان لا باس بذلك وقيل بانني
اقوم بعرقله الامر لانني كنت اتعامل بلطفا
حتى الى حين الغار التي تم شنها على منزلي
لكن بايدن كان قد حصل على اكثر من
18,500
مستند سري
واخيرا
وفي عمليه التحقيق هذه المره قيل بانه
تحقيق مدني من قبل عنصري اخري الذي ناصر
وتعهد بانني سوف انال مترام هذه كانت
الحمله بان سوف يتم منع من الترشح للرئاسه
واتحدث هنا عن التيشا جيمس
وادعت اثناء المناصره بانني سوف اتوجه الى
مكتب النائب العام كل يوم لمقاضته وبعدها
اتوجه الى منزلك قبل ان تعرفني ايضا
واعلنت بانه ما الذي
يضايق
يضايقني الان هو ان ترامب وكانت تركز فقط
على شخصيه ترامب
لم اكن اعلم او اعرف تلك الشابه وقد وعدت
في الانتخابات بانها سوف سوف نعمل على
مقاضته وسوف نتسبب له بالاذيه والالم وسوف
يعلم باسمي بصوره شخصيه
ومن ثم ادعت
بانني كنت
رئيسا غير شرعي رغم كل ما فعلناه ثم ورغم
كل الطاقه التي رغم كل الامور التي
فعلناها في قطاع الطاقه
القوات العسكريه وما قدمناه
للتاريخ الان شاهدوا ما الذي يحدث الناس
بات بمقدورهم
كان بمقدور الناس ان يحصلون على الادويه
الطبيه دون اي مشاكل
والان نجد ان مكتب النائب العام يقوم
بمقاضره الرئيس ترامب على تلك المعاملات
التجاريه التي يزعمون بها
وسوف نلاحقه ونطارد اسرته بشده
هذا الامر كله قبل حتى دخول مكتب الرئاسه
ومعرفه اي شيء كلهم كانوا يرغبون بالنيل
من لذا فالحديث عن تلك الجرائم
التي تحدث لا يمكن تصديقها حتى ان احدهم
فلير قالوا بانني قد زورت
احقيتي في الملكيات العقاريه الخاصه بي
وفي جميع الحالات
هناك
مواد قانونيه
تملي بانه لا يمكن الوثوق
ما قدموه في قضيتهم
لانهم رغم كل ما قدموه لا يمكن تصديق اي
شيء من فعل
وفيما وفيما يخص بالاصول
وحتى ان المصارف كانت هي الاخرى لم تخلو
من التحقيقيه رغم انها ان مصارفنا اتذكر
لم تخسر دولارا واحدا بنى حكميه للبلاد
بل عملته على زياده راس مالها
وايراداتها باكثر من 200 مليون دولار
وكانوا كلهم يحبونني
وقمت
باداره اعمال تجاريه رائعه مع اسرتي
[تصفيق]
لدي ابن هنا قام بعمل رائع
وباريس سوف يصبح رجلا عظيما ذات يوم
ولدي اسره عظيمه قد ابلت بلا ان حسنه
[تصفيق]
لذا فانها تقاضيني بشان العمليات التزوير
في المصارف في حين يجدر بها ان تركز على
الجرائم والعنف في الشوارع هذه مساله
اضطهاد فقد وضعت اسرتنا في محنه كبيره وتم
انف
لكن رغم ذلك سوف نبقى شامخي
شامخين في وقفتنا وفي الدفاع عن انفسنا
وها نحن الان
وحيث ما وصلت اليه الاحداث اليوم هذه
المدينه
التي كانت عظيمه ورائعه قبل بضع سنوات
ولكن
من خلال
ادعاء عام يقوم باتهام رئيس سابق للولايات
المتحده في اول سابقه لتاريخها
ومحللون قانونيون قالوا بانه ما من قضيه
لا يوجد قضيه لها اي اساس
وبصوره حرفيه كل كل شخص قد ذكر نفس الشيء
ولهذا فان في الاسبوع الماضي كان هناك
تاخير في
تقديم لاحد الاتهام ومع ذلك تم تسريعها
وقالوا المحامون لي بان هما من شيئا قد
فعلته
المجرم هو
المجرم الحقيقي هو
[تصفيق]
النائب العام
والتي
فيجب مقاضته او يجب ان يستقيل قد اكدت بان
زوجه
قد قال بانه قد نال من ترامب بسبب تلك
التهم وبعد ذلك تم اغلاق حساب هذا ما ذكره
المدعي الرئيسيين الذي يمثل الديمقراطيين
قد وتم تاكيد هذا الامر من قبل لشقيق جاك
تشومر قد
قد وضع امرا للدعاء العام
من
اجل التقدم
بطلب الاتهام كان يمكن ايضا مقضاه كلينتون
لكن براج لم يخل له لم يخل له بان هناك
قضيه يجب التحقيق بها انهم يجرون هذا
التحقيق
وايضا يقاضون الذي نشر كتابا
وقيل بان
وقد تم توبيخه بشده
بشان ما نشره من محتوى في ذلك الكتاب لكن
ما قاله لعل ما قام به
ان لم يكن امرا غير قانوني ومع ذلك تم
توبيخه ورغم
حاله الاختلاف بينه وبين البنبراج معدله
مضت الامور لكن القضيه لم تنتهي حتى
اللحظه
لانهم خالوا
لانهم خالوا عن البئر
بانه قد
تم توجيه هذه الاتهامات
لكن الامر لم ينتهي حتى اللحظه حتى ان
النائب العام لديهم صفحه على الانترنت
وتحمل عنوانا
قابلوا فريقنا الذي استطاع النيل من دون
ترامب في حين ان الجرائم في نيويورك قد
ارتفعت بوقع ثلاثين في المئه اكثر من
السنه التي سبقتها وكذلك ايضا عمليه
السرقه
التي تنتشر كالنار في الهشيم هذا ليس
المكان الذي عهدته وعرفته ولهذا السبب
فاننا نحن الان لدينا
جمله من القضاه
واحد واحدهم تعمل ابنتها لكمل لنائبه
الرئيس كما لهارس
وفي محاكمه اخرى كنا قد شهدنا قاضي
اصدر حكم على شخص بالسجن لمده تسعين يوم
وقيل له بانه ان لم يقرب الذنب ان لم قرب
الذنب
والكلم موجه لي وان لم يقرب الدم فانه سوف
يقمع في السجن لمده سنوات ما فعله القاضي
والادعاء العام هو امر لا يصدق
وقالوا ان ذكرت اي شيء عن ترامب فهذا امر
سيء وبعد ذلك
انخضعت للحكم
المحدد ب 90 يوما فبعدها انت حر
هذا ما حدث مع جاكس ميث المجنون الذي كان
يهدد الناس بصوره يوميه يهدد بالسجن
ولكن انت تحدثت عن ترامب فانت حر
ويسعون
لتزوير ما حدث في صناديق الاقتراع هذه هي
البلاد التي نعيش فيها الان حاله من
الفوضى التضخم خارج عن السيطره روسيا قد
انضمت او انضمت مع الصين والسعوديه مع
ايران السعوديه
والصين وكوريا الشماليه
وهذا تحالف
مدمر لم نشهده له ولما كنا لنشهده لو كنت
رئيسا وكذلك حتى حرب اوكرانيا لما كانت
لتندلع لو كنت رئيسا ولما كنا شاهدنا
دماره تلك المدن الجميله
ومعايير العالم كلها انقلبت راسا على عقب
وهذه اكبر هزيمه قد يمنع بها اليمنى بها
على مر المئتي العام
الماضيين وسوف يبعدنا لان نكون عن مصافي
الدول العظمى
وكذلك ايضا
لو كنت في سده سلطه لما عشنا هذا الدمار
الذي تسبب به بايدن وادارته
[تصفيق]
بصوره
فارقه
بلاد
وفاشله
وهؤلاء المجانين من
اليسرين يرغبون باستخدام
وكالات انفاذ القانون لكننا لن نسمح بحدوث
ذلك
[تصفيق]
مع كل ما قيل
ومن خلال هذه الغيمه السوداء
التي تخيم على بلادنا الحبيبه ما من شك
لدي البته باننا سوف نجعل امريكا عظيمه
مجددا شكرا جزيلا
بكم فليبارك الله بامريكا شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]